mr. Lewis thank you for coming in with
your associates I know this is hard to
hear but we need to make some serious
decisions about your mother's health
let's be honest she is getting on in
years
oh yeah okay I see how it is I see how
it is well yo mama so Oh her last name
is a Soros no mr. Lewis it wasn't an
insult I I was just saying that your
mother's condition is deteriorating
because she's getting older Oh see
that's cold though that's a cold one
okay okay I see how it is oh yeah yo
mama so old in her history class they
just wrote down what they was doing
insult contest not only is your mother
elderly but also her ability to walk is
currently being affected by her weight
Oh see okay it just got real no I'm not
insulting her I'm trying to tell you yo
mama is so fat wish you go to the movie
theater bitch sitting next to every way
[Music]
[Applause]
your mother needs to manage her weight
or there can be some real problems so
fat she need a latitude and longitude
double to find her old ass
[Applause]
who's the doctor mr. Lewis I am and it's
my job to make sure that your mother is
getting the care that she needs we are
talking about the woman who took care of
you your whole life the least you can do
is take care of her and her old age and
take this seriously I'm sorry I'm sorry
that I lost my temper no really doctor I
guess I was just joking around because I
know her condition is really serious and
I don't know I guess humor is the only
way I could really deal with it I just
know that she says so many times she
doesn't want anything invasive died Phil
even I was not aware of that that that's
interesting because she did not mention
that to me in our previous conversation
of course it was difficult to hear her
with my dick in her mouth
snap mr. Lewis oh snap now let's talk
about the procedure
you